it was a hard to define protest
free palestine was a strong theme
anti-austerity
next in line
black lives matter were here too and
extinction rebellion brought their
drummers
the march was a well-trodden path
through london to parliament square
but it's an activity these protesters
fear is under threat
well they may come from lots of
different groups representing a plethora
of
issues but they are all opposed to one
thing and that is the police
crime sentencing and courts bill which
they think could be
occurred on their right to protest in
the future
many here are out for the first time
since the restrictions on gatherings
were lifted after lockdown
and they're concerned the new
legislation will bring new kinds of
restrictions
against primarily the fact that we're
not going to be able to protest very
soon
so i've come to show my color there's a
bit of love
we're still going to be allowed to
protest don't we i don't know
it's a direct violation of our freedom
of speech and our freedom to protest
the government doesn't like it because
they know they're wrong they know
they're not being just and fair
and they don't want us to talk about it
the bill states that a fair balance
should be struck between individual
rights and the general interests of the
community
it cites extinction rebellions protests
of 2019
where parts of london came to a
standstill affecting commuters and
businesses
it will allow police to impose
conditions such as start and finish
times
and maximum noise levels on protests
however the bill states
this power can only be used when the
police reasonably believe that the noise
from the protest
may cause serious disruption to the
activities of an organization
or cause significant impact on people in
the vicinity of the protest
impact is defined as intimidation
harassment serious unease
serious alarm or serious distress the
police and crimes bill is a major threat
to our liberties in this country which
effectively will
give the police power to control whether
we demonstrate or not
and that would be an affront to
democracy anywhere in the world
including here
and so amid all the other issues a new
battleground for protesters is emerging
the right to protest itself to disrupt
and cause
unease and alarm jason farrell sky news